welcome to this video this is Round four
right round for this coverage of the
gushing off memorial currently playing
in chunkier Azerbaijan yeah this is a
bit late I know but I really couldn't do
the video on Monday evening after
finishing my life show him yeah when it
got close to midnight so a bit late this
video still let's have a look at the
games round form and we're going to
start here with Maxim Rashida graph with
white against kawana yeah coronet lost
the game in the round before and yeah
let's see how we recovered in this game
we have a good felt and the first term
and yeah unfortunately almost lost
interesting moment at this game is
coming right here because Maximus
Telegraph goes for night a for this is a
very strange-looking move right but it
is something that is nowadays we are
well known it has been played first time
by Anna minion granted nowadays crew
think he's a grandmaster not done young
and also a second to levon aronian Janna
Danielle played this in the in the
mid-90s this honeymoon I day for the
idea is that white wants to go e form
push the Black Knight back and then
return to see three so keeping more
pieces on the board and avoiding any
mainstream gruenfelder e now black has a
number of options CM and Kara wanna went
45 he took a moment down a couple of
minutes and then when 25 um I think
maybe one idea behind the MV else choice
it was that car wanna um earlier in the
tournament had this situation against
Muhammad yarrow for he had forgotten all
his preparation in the green felt and
had to play over the board maybe he
wanted to surprise him with this offbeat
line yeah he 5y takes it and now 96 yeah
in the very first game with this line
thomas bishop before played i'm going to
show that because just a very funny line
Bishop t2 and now black has this um a
really really a nice move 93 yeah why
takes with the pawn there's nothing else
cakes cakes check and you get this back
yeah first impression is wow isn't this
great for black here White has a triple
porn but the problem is that like it's
not easily getting the pawn back there
he's upon down he's not getting you five
easily and there are still dark squared
weaknesses to worry about this in fact
has a pretty dodgy reputation and
nowadays for black and was avoided by
Caruana then move nights is six seems to
be stronger and in fact they follow some
some already known games for a couple of
moves white will return the pawn yeah
now Bishop before was a much stronger
thread so white has to do something
about it a three and now black gets the
pawn back yeah and unfortunately we get
check check number of trades here check
yeah white has gaining it against a
little bit of time here with this this
development with check but black is not
really in any substantial danger with
the Queen's traded the King in the
middle is no problem yeah let's have a
look wide web looks a little bit active
here with the night on c5 but well this
is going to be traded off on sand back
let's say yeah here we have a trade and
here black has absolutely no problems
whatsoever so what I think is that here
in the mdl he was out for a surprise and
hope that karana wasn't kind of familiar
anymore with this line which is really
out of fashion 9 a-4 but while we see
that we just in an end game and they
basically traded down everything even to
a king and porn and game yeah and here
there's nothing really going on yeah you
can can maybe argue that okay well isn't
this an outside put potential outside
pass
you had true but well you don't ever get
to a passer white is just just staying
here yeah they went to see a 55 and now
it got totally closed down yeah so it
was some a little bit of a
disappointment after this enterprising
opening but well sometimes the most
reliable lines involve those
simplifications and this is this is it
seems one of those some one of those
cases um yeah I didn't know the theory
about 94 but I looked up that if I've
seems to be reliable and yeah Kara wanna
just played it to to equalize the game
okay let's have a look at the next game
which is Giri with white playing
mamedyarov okay we got a sloth defense
with e3 yeah the early 90 3 III line is
um an old favorite of mine i have to
admit i've played this on quite a lot in
the in the 90s early 2000s the idea is
that with this move order wyd want it as
i want it because the move is coming now
wanted to prevent Bishop f5 yeah why was
it belief that Bishop f5 is prevented
yeah after Bishop f5 White has the
opportunity to take and play queen bee
three and according to a theory like 20
years ago this was supposed to be good
for white because this porn Hanks and b7
hangs but there is a recent development
down knight c6 queen bee 7 Bishop d7 bit
of a weird maneuver with the bishop out
and then back to the seven but it is in
fact quite tricky for why to handle this
position um what is down in terms of
development it has to lose even more
time with the Queen this typical pawn
rate on b7 here it usually continues
like this between b3 rupee aid and why
it goes all the way back now e5 yeah
black has an excellent development and
turn this line was pretty obscure even
some years ago but then it was also
analyzed by well well known theoretician
Boris a ver up in one of his books the
classical sloth and he gave it his stamp
of approval so what is that what does
this mean for this game let's just go
back this was played by mamedyarov so we
actually invites Giri to take this pawn
in essence but Giri declined that's an
interesting message for theoretically
focus players as white means that ok
Gary seems to believe that black
handsome enough compensation there or he
was surprised and didn't want to want to
risk to go into this line um the whole
thing is not like something terrible for
White Knight f3 it just transposase to
another known variation but it means
that the Knights III III move order that
usually had this point to prevent Bishop
f5 seems to lost some have lost a little
bit of bite and however the acceptance
of the pawn on sacrifice is debated
among the auditions I remember that I
recently saw young gustafson talking
about this line the German GM and he
said he does not believe what has any
problem then like just have insufficient
compensation so an open an open issue
but Giri avoids this he plays Knight f3
now mamedyarov goes for a six
interesting move order why a six you can
come to this move by if you want by
process of elimination what else is
there for black e6 is the normal move
and something that has been played yeah
hundreds of times after that white gets
in night H form and will gain the bishop
pair not not terrible for black as
mentioned test plate been played
hundreds of times but some players with
black want to avoid that what else do
you have then if you don't want to play
your six unfortunately there are not
that many moves yeah you can for example
do something like h6 um and trying to
give you a gig give them give a sweater
on age seven in this case the queen bee
three idea of course gains in strength
yeah for example C takes see takes queen
bee three and now you are really not
able to sacrifice the problem that have
to go back all the way to c8 to keep
your things together so it's a bit
tricky this is move order a sick source
of 18 move the idea said after queen bee
three you have to move be five or
sometimes rugae seven it depends a
little bit on the precise move order
okay so some info about this opening
line Bishop a six was played Bishop e2
h6 Bishop b3 I know that looks very
strange but it has been has been tried a
bit in recent in recent times um it's
the region of this ideas of course
Bishop d3 yeah after takes takes e6 we
get almost the same position but here
black has played h61 difference is that
in the situation with their Verde Bishop
d3 here black has some additional
options he can play six if he likes um
it's not super reliable but it's an
alternative with h6 being plagued this
look so this loot loses some appeal as
the pawn they are really does not want
to be on h6 you want to have everything
on light squares then and the other
ideas that in this kind of structure
when white opens up later with e4 black
is more flexible with the pawn on h 7 ER
with the pawn on age 6 it's just a very
very minor minor detail but something
that is some looked at nowadays um
here's an interesting moment white now
when a three kiwi smooth um in this kind
of situation white cannot go a form of
course this is important as what has to
face this move and we Lucy form so
Bishop before it's a play to prevent you
form there's a tactical ever 9065 funny
funny move sometimes this is even
winning a pawn and if you had this
situation with the night on d7 like
really an extra move white would really
win upon but in this case it's not
happening it's a it's a discover to
check of course if black takes here we
wish had a big center pond but black has
95 keeping before covered takes takes in
the position if this would be a night on
d 7 now white could actually play the
intermediate move d take c6 attacking
this night and he will at the end emerge
with an extra porn being this temple
down is actually have been officially fo
black as him he has no problems
whatsoever white has to take back the
bishop now black takes and we have a
completely equal position okay maybe
white has a mmm and nibble yeah with
Knight B 3 and so on but it's it's very
very little yeah in the game you went a
three and now Mammadyarov went for a
very straightforward solution taking
taking 25 so what is basically saying is
okay i'm giving up the center for the
moment but i will establish a blockade
on the light squares yeah like c4 c4
those squares are controlled by black's
pieces to be honest it looks a bit ugly
right with with the night back on be
eight and so on but it seems that white
really has nothing great that you can do
I think Kira's plays very logical he
goes for a central break he after those
moves first he goes on the queenside and
now he switches to the idea to play a
central break here with with e form it's
all very logical but it seems that
ultimately it doesn't lead to lead
anywhere blacks a counter plays some is
good enough a5 yeah just against you for
f3 and c5 and it seems that black is
perfectly fine him he's a bit behind in
development but he seems to be catching
up very quickly and this now is a a
pretty for sequence that those trades
took on b5
yeah I now we see blacks strong
counterplay here d 5 is an interesting
idea the last trial at same to get
something out of this position before
I'd gets traded down two to nothing yeah
this happened would be five Queen D
session check Queen f7 check that was
giving idea I giving up a pawn for a
temporary initiative but ultimately it
doesn't lead lead to much jus k7s
defending I think we have a situation
where white is having enough for the
pond but mamedyarov some precise defense
some ultimately led to a complete can
get trade down of everything this is how
it how it ended with a five now even a
and B porn is is traded and they a
couple of moves later here it is they
agreed to a draw they are not a very
exciting game from the theoretical
perspective the only interesting thing
is that mamedyarov allowed this this
line here with Bishop f5 um or he sorry
he played this and allowed the pawn
sacrifice this is the right way to
phrase it um and I find interesting that
that going for this if we look at this
type of position that looks a bit
unconventional that this is some it
seems perfectly okay for black White's
bishop is not sorry that White's Bishop
on c3 is not really great and it seems
that black gum leg is fine okay let's
have a look at the next game we're going
to look at um what what are we going to
do next let's do chrome the guard yeah
let's see what we get here kramnik place
t4 and we get the semi Slav one of
Arlen's main defenses against Wandy for
yeah the semi Slava some is really a
very um very interesting and very sound
opening at the moment um not just at the
moment it's been so far quite a while
but yeah there are theoretical
states of openings and then fashion and
this is a very very M um yeah very
popular probably the nine nowadays um
yeah Cromley goes for g3 interesting
choice he has played this before of
course it's not something that comes as
a surprise it's a it's a sideline
traditionally but gaining more and more
popularity I think the main reason is
mostly not that this is such a great
line but that white is not getting much
with Bishop g5 in both age six and the
board Winnick or with e3 night bd7 in
this complex black i think aaron has
also very very decent chances so why
does looking for alternatives for new
ideas and g3 is one of them yeah what is
white trying to do he wants to ideally
play a catalan set up with Bishop g2
castles and asks black okay what are you
going to do in the center are you going
to take on c4 not the thing is if black
is not taking wish you did that it took
on c4 if black is not taking um black
will be basically forced to play close
catalan yeah which means let's say black
goes here this kind of thing 97 and now
there are many ideas 9223 in general
this is not believed to be a
particularly great setup for black it is
playable but it is much more passive
than then the open Catalan but black is
trading or taking on c4 early and tries
for counter play this is what wide wants
to have he wants this type of position
um and the only real way to technology 3
from blacks perspective is to take on c4
this is what Anna did 97 castles b5
that's that's the way to go for black
taking the pawn and keeping it and of
course this type of position the grab on
c4 and then keeping the pawn is
something that is well known
forum for a long time from the from the
Catalan but one difference is in the
Catalan opening usually white has not
played Knight c3 so often this is a big
difference in the dots to the move a
form yeah after a four for example if
why would we do that here black has
before with the tempo yeah this is
something that changes things completely
on the queenside is this temple yeah
what did chronic plane he went before
okay all all well-known we should be
certainly a note that after before white
has the movie 5 he does not give up the
e4 pawn just like that something like
this for example there's a funny funny
variation then why it is certainly very
comfortable he will get back one of the
pawns and has a nice position yeah so
Bishop d7 assume the normal move down
has been played quite a bit ly 595 and
95 yeah 95 is a typical attacking idea
getting this night near blacks king and
white tries to get asked we need to play
early on queen h5 Queen g-form those
kind of ideas and an additional idea is
that this a 45 push cleared the
foursquare for the night so sometimes
you just go night back to reform and
just play like nothing nothing ever
happened yeah why does a clear porn down
it's not like he's getting it back
quickly but he has compensation a very
very sharp position that is some
currently debated by many players um and
that goes for the move h6 now which is
some yeah the most straightforward way
to tackle the whole business either wide
retreats or he has to sacrifice um
there's also Bishop e7 this is the
alternative that recently for example
has been played by mamedyarov other
participant in this tournament after
Queen age five for example
g6 queen age 6 we had again a very
complicated position um he played this
against Pune my of only last year in
Beijing yeah h6 however is what island
plate and well now wyd really it's it's
a question of retreating not something
that you necessarily want in this
position or the kind of move that that
says okay I'm calling I'm calling your
yeah bluff if you want 90 x e6 just the
p secre feiss takes Queen 85 check yeah
black hair to take of course King is a
plane so we have a really really really
nice position now black had to play the
super ugly looking move King 37 but he's
a piece down how does right justify all
of that he went 90 for this is the idea
96 is a big threat now that's really
very substantial like cannot um yeah
ignore this idea if you play them let's
say some some non move 96 threatens
Queen to f7 mate and you have no way to
cover that I mean only with some
desperado things that that really don't
help at all why just has a fantastic
attack here a winning attack um so black
really only has one move Queen to e8
that was that's clear and so I think let
me have a look that my notes I think
this even has been played before right
yeah that that has been seen before this
idea Bishop g5 check that's a way to
justify the whole thing otherwise while
it's really just a piece down check
Bishop g5 and now black has a choice he
can take the bishop and give up the rook
in the corner or play Knight back to f6
this effect has been played before in a
game la leaf with white against England
only recently in 2015 and this position
is very very unclear I think one reason
may be why ding shows that line is that
he was like 200 points out awaiting his
opponent and maybe he wanted to try to
win this position
may be objectively let's this is how how
it went came to md aid Queen Jayde may
be objectively um why this is even a
little bit better you the computer for
example after 95 that was not played in
the original game prefers white but it's
a very very messy complicated position
where quite often simply the better
player will win not the one with an
advantage it's very unclear anyway it's
not like when the computer might like
white but it's a very irrational
position that Jung is this is difficult
very difficult to to assess but wish she
didn't play that he went night 5 2 F 6
and this is certainly part of
preparation um yeah it looks funny but
it's it's very forcing yeah widescreen
is also hanging here so there is no big
alternative there to cap taking this
back pawn takes yeah and now again
White's move now is almost forced he can
avoid them coming on simplification that
happens but not with something very
successful I mean you can take him and
go back just to show an alternative but
sheer white is a pawn down and it's not
so clear that he has sufficient
compensation yet I'm sorry that was a
long one yeah white choco f 69 txf 690
xf6 this was the mentioned
simplification that I that are already
announced yeah mmm no alternatives now
black camel take this as your rook drops
so you have to trade on age 5 and now
all of a sudden from this very very
spectacular sequence we got to an end
game with eco material funny right it
looked very spectacular but it is equal
material I think it is possible that
both players knew you about this I mean
look at the clock times they both spent
about 15 minutes so King f7 and a
four-year Kramnik took to quite some
time
I think actually that it was a very well
played game it looks like you have a
hard time to find any improvement let
alone on your own but even using the the
engines um a form looks really like the
way to go white should try something you
should never underestimate that white
has to deal with the two bishops at the
moment blacks pawn structure is not
looking very good this is isolated this
is kind of backward and under fire but
if flag untangle the two bishops will
mean something also note that there is a
potential form a passed pawn on the
queenside so white has to do something
at a 4 is a good idea trying to use
altars of temporary lead in development
and white hence he has all pieces in
play with a 4 but black is still sitting
there but it seems to be totally fine
for black anyway a 6 trade it I know
that I don't really see how to improve
rue k1 Bishop e7 back and the night was
coming back to f4 back into the game
yeah it seems that Bishop e7 rook a
seven root b8 all this is very very
logical that this ultimately leads to a
simplification what what Kramnik tried
is very interesting when Bishop ever
should be for trying to reroute the
night but after King f6 we see that
Nigerian to anywhere but I really don't
see an improvement what is it that white
white is supposed to try here to to
continue 96 why what why continue the
problem is after night is g6 Allen has
to move c5 yeah I'm technically am
motivated move because of the hanging
situation of this night on g6 now the
upcoming on sequences is basically
forced Ruby seven rugby sevens Bishop e7
and King takes 26 this position of the
night yeah now why it takes on c5 he has
to Bishop takes Bishop here yeah and
here we see that why do we win both of
those cons but after Bishop here
it should be five Bishop b2 Bishop c4 c5
f3 yeah a couple of models I think they
have a draw rule not to draw from before
to hear they agreed to the draw yeah it
is an opposite colored bishops end game
with the white being upon up this is a
very very simple draw I'm kind of
shocked that an engine like stockfish
gives wyd an advantage here of 0.6
that's really a really a bit
embarrassing yeah because I'm the way to
draw here for black is very easy just
sit yeah Black has two black simply um
can draw by just doing nothing you can
just shuffle your bishop forever and you
have to really don't ya f no no way to
lose the position white can push g4 h4
but he never ever God gets to g5 even
because you're just blockading on the
dark squares um in addition white has
the wrong colored bishop so it's it's a
total draw okay so our next game this is
Adams with white against the world
champion magnus carlsen cards and again
with the black pieces yeah he's starting
with the ton of tunnel black games okay
we have e 4 and the cars in place he
five as he usually does g6 interesting
choice here in the in the rural align
that she has played before the early g6
line um this is usually called dismissal
of variation but it is heavenly it's
very transpositional this line and in
fact we will see a transposition in the
game um to us I have looked at this line
quite quite often and thought why not
play that as black you know probably
that I'm playing e5 only for so I was
always interested in this move just to
also yeah get something a little bit of
beat in I never liked this line but this
is not played now by Adams and it also
was not played and yeah
nakamura when he faced carlton last year
and also g6 was played I never liked
this disposition he had this kind of
pollution this is normally what what
comes out of this and here I always
thought okay I'm never going to win ever
and probably in slightly worse and I
guess that cause and probably think that
he will simply hold this position as
black always found it a bit dry but it's
a yeah probably also from the white
player's perspective not super
attractive on that on that high level as
they probably think that cars and we'll
just draw this is endgame type of
position yeah okay c3 was played a six
you should a form of d6 and now we have
a transposition to the to the stein it's
deferred or the stein it's improved that
normally arises via a six Bishop a 46 c3
g6 this is the same position I'm not
quite sure why why garden is playing the
g6 move or they're not a 6-bit
mysterious I have some ideas but it's
it's not not completely clear to me why
does that okay so we get this deform
Bishop d7 and now why it goes castles
Bishop g7 the interesting thing about
this line for blankets that you get this
fianchetto in early quite often in the
way you play Bishop e7 castles yeah so
um yeah okay this is not easily possible
now but let's just I just want to show
the general idea I mean okay without
that we have g6 played on move three
yeah so okay very often black plays
Knight f6 Bishop e7 castles and later
goes rupee aid Bishop f8 so it's doing
the fianchetto later and loses a couple
of moves there and now with cousins way
of playing you have the bishop on g7
immediately of course this is not just
having upsides and also drawbacks and
here we see one drawback you have to
accept this black that you get this
Kings Indian type of structure where
your light square Bishop is trade it if
you know the Kings Indian your bit
do you know that giving up the light
squared Bishop can be tricky and this is
no exception here however one important
point is if we see f5 was played by
Colin black gets an f5 before I even
place 9f 60 he's very quick with his
counter plane and an important part of
the point is Adams not took on a five by
the way the important point is that if
white is not taking and keep keeps the
tension for example by this move then
after Knight f6 and three castles before
that was played by the camera against
the world champion in San Luis 2014 that
year black is not opting for an f4 based
play this kind of thing this looks like
the classical Kings Indian but you don't
have a light squared Bishop this is
really not a good idea like some blacks
attack won't be as dangerous as usual
without the light squared Bishop you
sometimes really need this piece to even
get G fine in the first place or
sometimes you need it for sacrifices
simply on age 30 g form here after and
c5 white is having a very substantial
advantage so Calvin did not play like
that in the game against nakamori played
c6 and we see a similar approach in the
game what black is doing his getting
form is going for an attack on white
center and in a way he uses his better
development here for for this pressure
to on the one on white on white center
white has played many pawn moves you
know be 45 and so on and black is nicely
coordinated and the game Adams took on
at five and G takes at five and one
thing that i should add here is that
adams was one of cards and some seconds
in the match last year so they worked a
bit together and this is also
influencing i think some some choices
there yet trying to play something that
the other might not expect so much or
varying a little bit it's comparable to
playing against your training partner if
you have
someone that you share opening ideas
with is always tricky to play against
such a person okay night age form and f4
that was Adams idea stopping those pawns
and maybe generating some play against
them but of course Carlton just pushed
forward and got this protected pass only
for of course that's not a pawn that is
easily promoting White has a square only
32 blockaded and we will see that in
effect pretty quickly and now c6 is
important what black has to avoid this
night coming to e6 of course this is
also why early on cars include the move
h6 he was worried about 95 b6 c6 as we
see it now is some very comparable to
the Nakamura game what center gets
attempt yeah and here I think we already
can conclude that black should be fine
in this position I think he has very
comfortably equalized with good central
control um I'd rather be black in this
position to be honest um but it doesn't
seem to be anything very substantial I
think this is all in all a very logical
game Bishop before black no went Queenie
6 looking at this pawn maybe the right
moment you can play d5 Luke see one
covering the pawn with this tactic look
f7 yeah so carbon is not going for
anything in the center he's setting up
for him play on the gphone well whitis
hazri rooted his knights to put pressure
on the f5 pawn it looks it looks
interesting for black gathers play on
the G file but on the other hand white
has also something to get counter play
against i think it's it's finely
balanced this position 98 night h5 like
two one two three an important momentum
and a moment where I think um yeah a
less some less experienced player might
make a mistake um you
absolutely have to be cautious in this
position if you check with the rook
after 96-94 black will get a fantastic
position note that those nights are
really far off and the knight on d4
would be in first place super strong in
itself another the power it has from d
forces is really really great and it
also blocks White's ball that was a
weird arrow blocks White's play along
the D file so here you have to really
absolutely take with the with the pawn
it's an absolutely that's a mandatory
move yeah you cannot allow black to come
to deform this is very often on
something that players them wrongly
evaluate they think okay it's a double
porn and this is a long-term weakness
and so on but quite often a double pawn
can provide a control of a crucial
squares and this is the case here white
controls to very crucial squares and
this is far more important than the pawn
structure at the moment and we also have
to see that black is not easily winning
one of those pawns in many endgame types
rook endgame for example it's absolutely
irrelevant this kind of structure so
Luke g4 was played g3 yeah and now cards
and tried an interesting an interesting
change in the position he sacrificed the
exchange on h4 yeah this is looking
spectacular but ultimately um it is
something that I think didn't yeah it
wasn't something that Karl's num had
huge problems with let's say um you get
the pawn you get to f3 it's pretty clear
that black will have sufficient
compensation it's difficult to tell if
you could more than that I think that
the next couple of moves I again very
logical looking at white puts the rukon
the G file and this way get some counter
play also against Blacks King the night
only three is very strong of course but
it is it's not clear how black shirt
increase or improve his position at the
moment of course widest to threatening
to take their so blank had to do
something he covered the Queen you can
also think about Queenie seven but
ultimately what exactly are you going to
going to do with the with the Queen's
there i was thinkin what did have Queen
g2 was my mammoth that I was thinking
after here you can just attack the Queen
and send it back it's very difficult for
both sides to really get get to
something substantial in the game we had
um yeah some some kind of it's not a
clear-cut threefold but it was a kind of
what is the word impasse yeah this is
the right word they both both sides
don't really have a way forward white
cannot easily let's say enter on the be
far as then he gets killed on the G file
he also always has to look at this night
the night is also controlling though
those squares and then yeah black can
put his night from EA to c7 but where
are you going from them it's a probably
just a kind of positional draw and so
sometimes call it it's not obvious that
it is a draw but it seems that both
sides have no way forward so a draw was
agreed here so we have draw draw draw do
we have a decisive game yes we have and
this is the game Westleigh so with white
against Mamedov I'm spoiling a little
bit but I'm not telling you who won
let's see what happened in this game we
have a Sicilian defense and then open
the Syrian and now g6 the accelerated
dragon this is a rather popular opening
among amateur players and it is it as an
interesting opening that has some some
some good points especially if Y display
Knight c3 I think black has some
interesting ideas that are related to
playing d7 to d5 in one move I've played
this a bit with black some years ago but
the problem is really this move them
oxy bind with c4 after that black has
some quite substantial problems to get
full equality even and if he gets
something that is close to equality it
is a kind of equality where you never
win a game so it's something that I
really prefer for wide very much we see
that Ramadan is going for this and now
after f3 he plays Bishop g7 it's
interesting news order black also can
take on d4 this was for example played
in a game Caruana cards last year the
same for your top this was game eight
after kawana seven straight wins and he
was very close of scoring with scoring
the eighth win against cards he had a
winning position at one point but but
spoiled it to a draw yeah mama dog was
going Bishop g7 there should be three
and did he play it here no castles
Bishop e2 yeah here you find dozens of
games in the database um very normal
looking position where black usually as
it takes or plays Bishop g7 both moves
or make perfect sense mahmudur forever
is coming with a different move Knight
to h5 quite surprising putting the night
on the edge but funny enough if you look
at this with an engine with houdini for
example it is one of the engines moves
so this is very often the way in rare
moves nowadays are put on the form the
engine says okay I don't see how to
refute it um and then players very often
just say okay if there's no clear
refutation why not try it out what is
blacks idea yeah the idea is that if
white is not reacting to this move and
he should look at this vessel a I play
g3 quickly so it was maybe prepared for
the idea that's interesting yeah the
thing is if why does not really paying
any attention then after castles for
example Black has night f4 as a funny
possibility this is possible pigs and
i takes or Bishop takes a certainly
something that black is welcoming
trading a pair of pieces and opening up
the bishops diagonal and the second
thing is that Queen B 6 isabels can be a
quite problematic be to hanks and
defines there are some really strange
lines for example my my engine was
giving this line which looks really
strange g 493 and all of a sudden check
it's a draw and what what kind of ideas
that and then it's a draw very strange
yeah so white probably really wants to
play g3 just controlling the square on
f4 okay 94 Bishop g4 there should be 6f
49 f 60 black has spent two moves night
h5 and back and in the meantime why
display g3 and therefore so what he
basically did is he provoked this
expansion what I find a bit mysterious
though on the next couple of moves okay
let's see Castle this looks totally
normal Ruby c8b three and we want to
keep the c-4 pawn and now mammadov
played the move Queen to a five after
some thought um it's I mean I don't know
maybe it's a case where the alternatives
aren't better but I rather would have
expected something I mean I'm not saying
this is great but I thought that maybe
something like that would be the idea to
have have provoked g3 let's say why it's
just that and maybe Queen d7 just trying
to put something on g4 this I thought
would fit somehow better with them with
this idea of provoking g3 and the second
thing that irritated me is you know this
is a actually in known position the only
difference between this position and the
position that is known is that g3 is an
extra move for white if you give this to
a data base and search for the position
without the move g3 this has been played
a couple of times because it can easily
arise without
having played night age five and back
and wide plank f4 in one move remember
that white played f3 f4 and Queen 85 is
believed to be bad for black in this
other position because of the move f5
which was of course played now and while
I was a bit surprised because this is a
completely this is totally known it's
some if you know the the theory of this
line and mamedov player plate that says
played this opening quite a bit um it's
kind of strange that he that he goes for
that it's not leading to a disastrous
position I'm not saying that but why
does he had definitely better just a
question of how much why is f5 even a
move first of all you have to see that
you cannot grab because before winds
straightaway Queen takes rook takes and
this is a piece and white even has an
attack on top of that so I'm terrible
position either the queen is threatened
temper trend to be to be trapped um
that's not possible at all so black has
to go back and now White has a number of
options queen bee three a three I had
this position on the board him in my own
games with the porn on GG to Iver and
well why does just an excellent shape um
a three was played one of the one of the
moves e six yeah it's difficult for
black how do you ever get counter play
here against the huge space advantage
you're simply very cramped and sometimes
it is even an idea for white to take on
f6 play 95 giving up the exchange then
own a one well a e6 be formed queen back
and now why just took on g6 a very
simple but strong solution black now um
will recapture h pawn or or f porn if he
goes with this move wyd will play a five
takes Bishop b5 yeah and in this
position white is better and this is
very much comparable to the game we had
the same situation in the game
what is better because his free porns
here um promised him promising chances
to get a passer ultimately on the
queenside he has much more space and the
better better pieces Bishop coming to a
three for example will be very annoying
also at the moment there's pressure on
this and this and we can really compare
this to the game yeah this is what
happened in the game in this situation
of course the e6 pawn looks like an
additional weakness but the open FR also
promises maybe some things I made some
trades at least for black yeah it is not
easy for me to assess this position here
after Bishop c6 or let's say easy is the
wrong word i can i can show you what i'm
thinking and then we compared to what
what the engine says it's sometimes
really an interesting interesting thing
ok why play b5 and 94 funny move to yet
to trade to trade pieces and what I'm
really kind of check yeah curious about
this is the following here this this end
game this arises pretty much by force
after this this sequence er starting on
move from of 20 around here this end
game is quite interesting if you ask me
I think what just wins this end game
with good technical play you have the
possibilities of creating a passer you
have more space your king is quicker in
the center um computer likes white but
it's not giving white a very substantial
advantage at least not Houdini and I
think white is just almost winning here
I mean his advantage is very very
substantial maybe i'm wrong i don't know
i would personally think that white has
excellent winning chances here black has
to go back yeah you cannot play actively
rupee 3 is not helping bishop here and
now why pushes the pawns up yeah a 4
there's really no big way for black to
improve all this is very normal Bishop
f3 and now you see that be 7 is the big
issue yeah what what what is that the
black and play not much look see some
king went over and now a five you just
push those pawns home there's absolutely
nothing black and do attack on the rook
damn check and see six it all flows very
naturally takes takes its what's traded
and now be seven black resigned that
this is just just to win in the rook
endgame with the room behind the pawn
wide Vince very easily let's say King
here King up yeah and ultimately we will
promote the pawn um the big question is
how bad was it from I mean I couldn't
really this I couldn't really determine
that to be perfectly honest I mean black
is definitely worse yeah that's
absolutely no question and yeah maybe
quite deservedly so as this Queen a 5
and so on isn't isn't really great but
I'm really not sure how bad it is if
there is a defense for black here um I
have my doubts I think white is very
much better but maybe someone is finding
with with closer inspection finding a
defense for black it looks very very
problematic white has the better
structure chances for the pass on the on
the queenside and and also as we as we
saw him yeah you're you're simply
quicker also with the king and you get
the king over to the Queen side where it
will ultimately help to promote pawns
it's a it's difficult for black very
difficult and probably probably simply a
bad position out of this out of this
opening when you allowed this this is f5
f5 IDM yeah so another win for Wesley so
and he's on plus three after four rounds
excellent score yeah I hope you enjoyed
this video coverage of the fourth round
and I'm back pretty shortly a couple of
hours later with round five I won't wait
until till Wednesday to upload that okay
thanks for watching